[Music]
we'll see after this place I know that
you will just say that I'm hipster and
I know you are grandpa so is that is
that the definition of a hipster you
dressed like a granddad no you like a
grandma whatever whatever okay listen
let's let's just go to the first
question is what kind of jeans do you
prefer I know they're right the right
answer to be a hipster is to say tight
skinny jeans that end at the ankle is it
yeah that's hipster all right not losing
baggy high-waisted that's for moms tell
me I like the the loose baggy jeans to
scuff the floor I don't want to say
tight skinny the other socks what the
[ __ ] is high-waisted I'm not gonna wear
something from a thrift store I'm tight
skinny jeans go [ __ ] you tight jeans
okay
what kind of cigarettes do you smoke I
don't smoke I don't smoke
is that a hipster is that hipster smoke
oh god no all right number three how
would you or did you financially support
yourself after college well I don't
think the answer start a YouTube
channels only job after I get out yeah
me too more like a seven-to-three job
yeah the Sweden's men how do you prefer
to get around a Prius is that a car
Hummer
that's also a car walking the [ __ ] is a
fixie I don't know what a fixie is fixie
that's the bike looks cool as [ __ ]
though I want a fixie you want a fixie
yeah I guess I'll pick a Hummer cuz I
usually Drive like a pickup truck so
which of these would you bring to a
party
Korona blue-ribbon olympia or smirnoff
ice what's the blue ribbon blue ribbon
it's is that that beard there was
something special about that beer Tony
is this the hipster beer oh why is it a
hipster beer I don't know there's just a
thing they went with it I think in
Corona Olympia
what's that I don't know that sounds you
can get Smirnoff ices and give them to
all the ladies yeah
no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that I don't give out
drinks they're my drinks all right your
friends is looking for new music wait
why I'm really yeah just turn on the
radio yeah you could just listen to
radio like everyone else you [ __ ] hit
[Music]
em a TV commercials featuring music from
unknown bands yeah you just turn on the
[ __ ] TV go there
your last FM page which is like an
online Spotify I think and your favorite
indie music music would you think any of
these not really I don't think though I
guess I have to pick the radio me I
would say my favorite in ain't I don't
read any music blogs um I don't know the
FM page is I would say a fan page yeah
okay it stores all your music kind of I
pick the radio okay alright it's only
tight last question number seven the
last question hipsters ball cat
society's definition of gender roles and
some things go for the on drugs
ingenious look what alle what do you
resemble the first one I'm a man and I
have mutton chops to prove it I'm a man
don't let this pink shirt for you I'm a
woman so what if I don't shave my
armpits I'm a woman just look at these
layered bangs ah I'm gonna pick I'm a
woman just look at these laid bangs
that's me all the way don't even worry
about it I like pink shirts uh I don't
have lamb chops okay I'm gonna go with
I'm a man
don't let this pink shirt fool you okay
continue let's see our results let's see
these results okay my results not a
hipster yeah says you are not a hipster
and that is okay with you sure you may
appreciate a good pair of skinny jeans
but I don't are a knit cap all right on
a chilly day but overall you like being
part of the mainstream society and don't
appreciate these stupid hipsters judging
you for
like what was that Kenny's a hit Jainism
ain't in the mainstream
you're just mainstream all right I'm
just a normal normal that's extra canna
- hey quiz that work all right
[Music]